par écrit mes vœux je vous présente mes
meilleurs vœux pour cette année c'est
notre première commission
de l'année depuis la reprise pour nous
c'est la dernière année utile de
mandatures européenne puisque le
Parlement européen suspendra ses travaux
en début 2024 en vue de son
renouvellement donc c'est une année qui
est particulièrement décisive
espérons qu'elle sera plus joyeuse et
prospère que la précédente même si les
indicateurs sont sombres mais l'espoir
fait vivre la suspension des travaux
parlementaires pour la fin d'année est
intervenu le 15 décembre soit le jour
même de la réunion du Conseil européen
nous avons donc pas pu entendre la
ministre nous en rendre compte puisque
d'habitude nous le faisons dans la
foulée
néanmoins c'est important de revenir sur
cette réunion des chefs d'État ou de
gouvernement et sur ses conclusions ce
que nous faisons ce matin alors qu'on
annonce à nouveau un Conseil européen
extraordinaire les neufs et 10 février
prochain alors l'ordre du jour du
Conseil européen de décembre il y avait
trois grands sujets
l'Ukraine l'énergie et la défense au vu
des conclusions adoptées j'aurais
souhaité vous faire part de quelques
interrogations madame la ministre
concernant l'Ukraine
les 27 conviennent qu'aucun crime qui
est commis ne doit rester impuni et que
les auteurs de crimes d'agression
ont à répondre
le Conseil européen réaffirme que c'est
poursuites concernent l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale et c'est à
dire que l'hypothèse d'un tribunal
spécial défendu par l'Ukraine et
aussitôt promise fin novembre par la
présidente de la Commission européenne
est écartée
par ailleurs le Conseil européen
réaffirmait son plein soutien l'Ukraine
et c'est tant mieux et il a confirmé
l'aide de 18 milliards d'euros que
l'Union entend fournir à l'Ukraine en
2023 nous interrogeons sur l'impact
financier d'un téléphone sur le CFP en
particulier sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel notre commission a eu
l'occasion d'en discuter en novembre à
la suite d'une communication de notre
collègue Patrice Joly
ceci nous préoccupe d'autant plus que
parallèlement et j'aborde ainsi le
second sujet à savoir la crise de
l'énergie et l'inflation qui en
découlent on entend de plus en plus
évoqué la perspective de mise en place
d'un fond de souveraineté qui serait
destiné à financer une réponse
européenne
au fameux ira un Flashion réduction Act
américain
pouvez-vous nous confirmer que la
création de ce fond pourrait être
décidée au prochain Conseil européen
extraordinaire de février
comment est-il prévu de le financer
alors que nous n'avons toujours pas mis
en place les nouvelles ressources
propres nécessaires pour rembourser
l'emprunt mutualisé souscrit pour
financer la relance post covid comment
échapper dans ce contexte à une révision
de fond du cadre financier pluriannuel
enfin concernant le sujet de l'énergie
pouvez-vous nous dire comment les choses
progressent quand il sera enfin apporté
une réponse européenne à la demande
française d'une réforme structurelle du
marché de l'électricité et d'une
politique industrielle ambitieuse pour
éviter les délocalisations d'entreprises
aux États-Unis ou l'énergie est moins
chère hier aux questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement la question était posée à
Madame panier runacher qui a dit qu'en
fait ce conseil du mois de février était
l'opportunité pour la France de faire
des annonces sur ce sujet donc peut-être
pourriez-vous nous en dire plus
s'agissant de la défense dernier grand
sujet du Conseil européen l'impulsion a
été donnée pour une adoption rapide de
l'instrument visant à renforcer
l'industrie européenne de la défense au
moyen d'acquisition conjointe
comment pourra-t-on satisfaire le besoin
légitime des États membres de
reconstituer rapidement leur stocks
d'armement à menuiser par la guerre en
Ukraine et en même temps encourager la
préférence européenne dans les achats
d'armement puisque l'industrie
européenne de défense n'est pas
aujourd'hui en mesure de fournir tous
les matériels nécessaires
je terminerai en évoquant un sujet
abordé en toute fin des conclusions du
Conseil européen qui est l'Iran c'était
déjà il y a un mois les 27 appelés alors
l'Iran à cesser tout recours à la peine
de mort et à la force contre les
manifestants pacifiques notamment des
femmes la situation n'a cessé de se
tendre depuis plusieurs de nos collègues
sénateurs ont d'ailleurs déposé il y a 8
jours une proposition de résolution
européenne appelant à renforcer les
sanctions européennes contre l'Iran et à
cesser l'application de l'accord de
Vienne sur le nucléaire iranien la
commission des affaires étrangères du
Sénat a pour sa part demandé le rappel
par les 27 de leur ambassadeur en Iran
quelle est la position du gouvernement
français sur ce dossier important madame
la mini je ne serai pas plus long vous
vous écoutons et après je laisserai
libre cours à mes collègues pour vous
poser des questions et merci par avance
des informations que vous pourrez nous
apporter
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup mesdames laissées natrices et
messieurs les sénateurs
pour cette année 2023 qui comme le
président vient de l'annoncer va être
riche à la fois en défi et je l'espère
en discussion dans votre beau Sénat
nous allons devoir parler tout au long
de l'année je crois de la suite des
mesures qui ont été pris cette année
pour combattre l'inflation l'énergie
continuer d'apporter du soutien à
l'Ukraine et en fait il répondra lira
donc avec une forte politique
industrielle c'est-à-dire faire ce que
ce que nous faisons depuis le début qui
est de renforcer à la fois les la
compétitivité intrinsèque de l'Union
européenne et sa solidarité
mais d'abord je vais vous remercie pour
cette invitation pour discuter des
résultats du Conseil européen qui
effectivement réunissait les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement les 15 et 16
décembre dernier vous l'avez mentionné
monsieur le Président évidemment la
guerre en Ukraine était bien sûr au
sommet de cet agenda et aussi c'est
conséquences sur la situation
énergétique et les situations
économiques des États membres de l'Union
les questions de sécurité et défense et
bien sûr le renforcement de la politique
industrielle qui je crois sera le
principal ressort de l'Europe face à
l'Iran
voilà puis il y a une petite discussion
aussi sur le voisinage sud et enfin un
événement important qui était l'octroi
du statut de candidat à la vision de la
Bosnie-Herzégovine
alors sur l'Ukraine tout d'abord vous
vous rappelez sûrement que ce Conseil
européen a permis de débloquer le
soutien macro-financier de 18 milliards
d'euros pour l'Ukraine ce qui va
permettre de les de d'assurer leurs
besoins structurels donc les écoles le
paiement des fonctionnaires la santé
tout ce qui fait la vie d'un pays
pendant toute cette période de guerre
c'était important d'y arriver avant la
fin de l'année pour que l'on puisse
débourser dès le début de cette année et
que les Ukrainiens bénéficient de cette
aide et en ce qui regarde en ce qui
concerne ce soutien à l'Ukraine je veux
d'abord saluer l'engagement constant de
cette commission mais aussi
votre déplacement monsieur le Président
puisque le bureau de votre commission a
pu échanger aussi avec la délégation
ukrainienne du Conseil de l'Europe le 29
novembre dernier c'est important que
nous ayons ces échanges à tous les
niveaux comme vous savez ça permet de
garder le lien et de les assurer ils en
ont besoin
de notre soutien constant
il y a eu également l'adoption du
neuvième paquet de sanctions à l'égard à
l'encontre de la Russie par le Conseil
le 12 décembre et puis nous avons eu la
mise en oeuvre du principe de
plafonnement parce que sur le transport
du pétrole russe vers les pays tiers
c'est important et cela n'a pas eu
d'effet sur les prix jusqu'à présent ni
sur l'approvisionnement ce qui est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour nous
le conseiller européen c'est aussi
accordé sur la nécessité d'accentuer le
dialogue avec les etatsières pour éviter
les contournements des sanctions et pour
maintenir l'impression sur la Russie et
puis enfin vous parliez du
renouvellement des stocks de défense
monsieur le Président cet accord a
permis de rehausser le plafond de la
facilité européenne pour la paix de 2
milliards d'euros supplémentaires donc
au delà du plafond initial qui était
déjà de 5,7 milliards et cela pour
poursuivre le soutien à l'Ukraine mais
comme vous le soulignez pour permettre
au pays de renouveler leur stock de
munitions d'armement et donc de garder à
la fois une capacité de défense mais
aussi de préserver les ambitions
globales du Fonds européen pour la
facilité européenne de la paix
et puis il y a eu aussi au mois de
décembre vous vous en souvenez essayer
de conférence organisée par le Président
de la République et le président
zéninski dont le but était d'aider les
Ukrainiens à passer l'hiver avec des
choses très basiques et très nécessaire
des générateurs des ampoules puisque les
frappes russes détruisent
systématiquement toutes les
infrastructures énergétiques notamment
de la Russie où les coupures
d'électricité sont maintenant menées
courantes parfois 8 heures par jour pour
tous les ménages ce qui est absolument
catastrophique
à cette Conférence de la Paix le 13
décembre il a été levé plus d'un
milliard d'euros dont 125 millions de la
France et qui vont permettre d'aider les
Ukrainiens à passer l'hiver
et puis vous avez le Conseil européen
aussi entériné des mesures sur l'énergie
puisque le 19 décembre dernier il y a eu
l'adoption d'un mécanisme de
plafonnement des prix de gaz sur le
marché c'est un mécanisme qui est
exceptionnel et temporaire et dont je
tiens à souligner qu'il visse
principalement à éviter les conséquences
de la spéculation donc il est prête les
hausses anormales de prix du gaz sur le
marché et ça c'est bien parce que c'est
à la fois une réponse au profiteur de la
guerre et une réponse à nos
consommateurs pour faire baisser les
prix
il y a eu également deux autres textes
dans le domaine de l'énergie
le premier relatif au développement des
énergies renouvelables au sein de
l'Union européenne et le second la mise
en place d'une plateforme d'achat
conjoint de gaz là encore pour agir sur
les prix et nous pourrons y revenir
voilà c'est mesures complètent les trois
règlements qui avaient été adoptés dans
le contexte d'urgence que nous
connaissons je crois qu'elles seront
extrêmement importantes pour la
souveraineté énergétique de l'ensemble
de l'Union européenne
je crois qu'il faut que jamais qu'on
garde qu'on oublie il faut vraiment
toujours qu'on garde en tête le fait que
toutes les actions qui ont menées dans
le domaine de l'énergie depuis le début
de la guerre elle vise à assurer la
sécurité d'approvisionnement les prix
les moins élevés possible tout en
mettant fin à notre dépendance
énergétique vis-à-vis de la Russie et
vis-à-vis des énergies fossiles et pour
ça et nous allons continuer là dessus la
réduction de notre consommation
d'énergie est clé c'est elle qui permet
le mieux la baisse des prix et qui
permettra aussi d'assurer à notre
autonomie en matière d'énergie
lors de ce conseil d'ailleurs il a été
donné un cap sur la suite de ce qui des
actions qui devaient être prises en
matière d'énergie et de sécurité
d'approvisionnement et nous pourrons en
reparler vous avez été assez
instrumental pour mettre des idées sur
la table notamment avec le premier
dessin en la table ronde que vous avez
organisée sur le marché d'électricité au
sein de l'Union européenne à nouveau
nous pourrons parler de la réforme de
l'électricité à l'heure de cette ce
matin
vous avez évoqué monsieur le Président
la réponse de l'Union européenne à
l'inflation réduction Act et oui il y a
effectivement un conseil extraordinaire
les neuf et 10 février qui va parler à
la fois de cette réponse à l'IRA et un
des sujets des migration il y a un
consensus parmi tous les États membres
pour dire que le
fossé de compétitivité les quarts de
compétitivité entre les États-Unis et
l'Union européenne créée à la fois par
les prix de l'énergie et cette mesure
américaine est importante et nécessite
une réponse il est hors de question de
voir nos entreprises qui étaient le
territoire européen
et ça vraiment j'étais aussi au Conseil
Compétitivité qui est le premier à avoir
parlé de ça c'est un vrai consensus
parmi les États membres donc il a été
demandé à la Commission de présenter une
stratégie pour répondre
assez défi et nous avons travaillé aussi
avec l'Allemagne à une telle réponse
c'est clair et ces quatre étapes la
première c'est évidemment des
discussions avec les Américains pour
faire en sorte que toutes les marges de
manoeuvre possible dans ce projet soit
utilisé pour rétablir des conditions
équitables de concurrence entre l'Union
européenne et les États-Unis
la deuxième chose c'est que nous devons
être plus fort et plus malin c'est donc
accélérer toutes les procédures qui
existent pour financer des secteurs
stratégiques dans l'Union européenne
c'est simplifier ces procédures c'est
augmenter les aides d'État mais pas que
parce que sinon nous allons créer des
distorsions entre pays de l'Union
européenne entre ceux qui peuvent en
faire beaucoup et ceux qui ne peuvent
pas en faire beaucoup et il faudra donc
c'est clair des financements
supplémentaires pour s'assurer que nous
ayons des conditions pour les
entreprises équitables dans l'Union
européenne
et on pourra revenir là-dessus dans les
réponses aux questions mais je crois que
il y a vraiment et j'ai beaucoup parlé à
la fois au commissaire et au pays depuis
la rentrée un consensus qui est en train
de se former autour de ses actions
décisives y compris et on prend y
revenir sur le fond de souveraineté que
vous avez mentionné
il y a eu d'autres sujets on vous avait
mentionné la sécurité la défense
monsieur le Président le premier étant
la cybersécurité évidemment nous voyons
les crises et des attaques se répéter et
cela impose de prendre des mesures en
européen pour protéger nos
infrastructures essentielles et aussi
pour protéger nos institutions
démocratiques parce que parmi ces
attaques bien fois des attaques sur les
hôpitaux mais sur les systèmes
d'information et comme vous savez
beaucoup d'utilisation du numérique pour
déformer la réalité des choses
et c'est donc six enjeux qui sont au
cœur d'une série de textes sur le point
d'aide finalisé dans le cadre de la
politique européenne de cyber défense
nous espérons qu'il y aura des
conclusions au conseil à faire
étrangères en mai et juin 2023 et que
nous allons atteindre ainsi un niveau de
cyber sécurité et de résilience des
infrastructures qui nous semblent
aujourd'hui vraiment indispensable
et puis ça a été aussi cette question de
résilience des infrastructures critiques
l'objet du Conseil justice et à faire
intérieur des 8 et 9 décembre 2022 et
c'est là dessus qui a reposé l'action du
Conseil
il y a également eu une session sur le
voisinage Sud comme vous le savez il y
aura un sommet qui sera présidé par
l'Espagne pendant leur présidence du
conseil au deuxième semestre 2023 bien
évidemment l'idée c'est de promouvoir un
agenda positif avec des projets concrets
notamment en matière de sécurité
alimentaire énergie à nouveau pour en
créer aussi ces pays dans le camp des
démocratie et de l'état de droit
ce qui m'amène aux relations extérieures
et aux Balkans occidentaux le Conseil
européen a donc endossé les conclusions
du Conseil sur l'élargissement qui avait
été adopté le 13 décembre il y a donc eu
accord contre très consensuel sur
l'octroi à la Bosnie-Herzégovine du
statut de pays de candidat à l'Union
européenne dans le contexte géopolitique
que l'on connaît qui est vraiment celui
des
ingérences déstabilisatrices de la
Russie en plus de la guerre qu'elles
mène à l'Ukraine c'était important je
crois pour l'Union européenne de donner
à la Bosnie à un témoignage concret de
sa perspective européenne c'est fait
c'était aussi l'occasion de deux choses
d'abord d'envoyer un message de soutien
à la population bosnienne mais aussi de
rappeler l'ensemble des réformes qui
vont être nécessaires en Bosnie pour
l'arrivée véritablement comme candidat à
l'adhé pour accélérer son accession à
l'Union européenne
ce qui m'amène ensuite à la communauté
politique européenne sur quand on parle
des Balkans c'est toujours quelque part
près d'ici et là je voudrais insister 2
minutes sur l'importance de la
diplomatie parlementaire
à la fois parce que ça nous permet de
promouvoir des liens vraiment forts avec
nos partenaires et je sais que vous en
faites beaucoup en la matière ce fil
continue de présence et extrêmement
important donc nous sommes très
reconnaissants je pense aussi à la COSAC
monsieur le Président et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est une
enceinte importante et je crois que la
France il y a une forte capacité
d'influence je sais que vous aviez été
un peu déçu quand on en avait parlé la
dernière fois mais je voudrais vraiment
que vous
que vous persévériez parce que on entend
parler et ça et ça apporte vraiment des
fruits je crois c'est une discussion
remonte et diffuse
je pense aussi au groupe d'amitié
parlementaire et je ne sais pas si la
présidente Martha de Sidrac et là non
voilà j'ai aussi vu que la Commission
c'était entrevue avec une délégation
d'Albanie le 13 décembre dernier et avec
l'Assemblée parlementaire pour
l'Organisation pour la sécurité et la
coopération en Europe monsieur le
président Pascal Alizard
sur là on gris je voudrais revenir un
tout petit peu sur la mise en oeuvre qui
était la première du mécanisme de
conditionnalité de fonds européens
la Commission européenne et les États
membres comme vous le savez vraiment un
coeur et met en oeuvre une action très
très forte pour faire face aux attentes
à l'État de droit et ce partout sur le
territoire de l'Union Européenne et en
Hongrie on regarde l'ampleur des risques
importants aux intérêts financiers de
l'Union européenne il y a eu ce
mécanisme avec les risques
identifiés documentés analyser et pour
la première fois la Commission
européenne a actionné le mécanisme de
conditionnalité
il a porté ses fruits ce n'est pas fini
mais il a porté ses fruits puisque la
Hongrie a déjà donné des gages concrets
en s'engageant à mener des réformes dans
la lutte contre la corruption ce n'est
pas fini comme vous savez les prochains
mois vont être cruciaux pour s'assurer
de la mise en oeuvre des textes qui ont
été agréés entre la Commission et la
Hongrie et puis bien sûr de son suivi
pour s'assurer que c'est efficace dans
le domaine de la lutte contre la
corruption notamment je crois qu'il faut
déjà se féliciter qu'on ait pu avoir ce
dialogue qu'il se soit bien passé entre
la Commission et Budapest et évidemment
que nos valeurs soient respectées là
aussi fort consensus des états
voilà monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs ici Naters le programme de ce
Conseil européen était
exceptionnellement chargé il a reflété
vraiment je crois à l'unité continue des
États membres face à l'Ukraine et sans
vouloir laisser de côté les sujets plus
structurants
je crois que je vous commenciez à vous
répondre sur le sujet du prochain
Conseil européen peut-être juste un mot
sur votre question en ce qui concerne le
tribunal international monsieur le
Président
la France lutte et soutiendra tous ceux
qui luttent contre toute forme
d'impunité comme vous le savez peut-être
l'envoyer spécial de l'Ukraine sur le
sujet du tribunal international a été
reçu à Paris avant l'année dernière
puisque il s'est l'année dernière à la
fin de l'année sur cette question la
solution que nous cherchons c'est
d'éviter
de s'assurer qu'il n'y aura aucune
impunité et d'avoir à la fois une
solution qui permet de recueillir le
soutien de la communauté internationale
dans son ensemble donc les travaux
avancent et nous allons nous diriger
vers une solution j'ai bon espoir que ce
soit fait assez vite merci
merci madame la ministre avant de passer
la parole et il y a cinq demandes de
prise de parole revenir quelques
instants en tant que président sur vos
propos
tout d'abord effectivement sur le sur le
prochain conseil vous nous avez répondu
sur sur la question du tribunal
international
mais en relation directe hier avec les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement je
vous ai dit que Madame panier renachez
avait dit que la France ferait une
proposition sur sur le marché de
l'électricité donc je sais pas si vous
avez le droit de nous en dire plus mais
c'est important qu'on est dans dans nos
travaux cette cette nécessaire
connaissance de ce qui va se se dire
tant la pression à l'extérieur et quand
je dis à l'extérieur c'est à l'intérieur
de la France est forte un point sur
l'irra effectivement vous m'avez répondu
aussi sur sur les rats j'ai simplement
un petit regret et au regard d'audition
que qu'on mène avec vice-président
Didier Marie sur sur le marché européen
on se rend compte que l'OMC finalement
est un outil qui est très faible très
très faible parce que je pense que
au-delà de au-delà de la conjonction des
États membres sur sur la question de
Lyra et la réponse à y apporter je crois
que l'OMC serait aussi un outil très
intéressant pour répondre à ce genre de
question mais donc acte c'est un c'est
un état sur la cosaque bah écoutez merci
de votre soutien
et votre soutien m'incite à ne rien
lâcher mais néanmoins je pense que enfin
voilà
où l'outil doit être réformé ou il doit
être il doit être repensé c'est un outil
qui avait été fait pour les parlements
nationaux et je vous le dis sincèrement
la puissance et la force du Parlement
européen est beaucoup trop prégnant sur
l'outil cosaque qui a été qui était
destiné au départ au Parlement nationaux
et donc à partir de là on a l'impression
que la parole des parlements nationaux
était tout fait en tout cas elle est
vraiment
très très sommaire par rapport à ce que
les parlements nationaux pourraient
apporter je crois à l'Union européenne
mais vous savez que c'est mon light
motiv et je continuerai à le porter un
petit point que nous n'avons pas évoqué
mais en aspect diverse on sait que entre
l'Espagne et la France un traité va être
promulgué dans très peu de deux temps on
a quelques sujets d'État de droit avec
l'Espagne sur notamment la suppression
de du délit de détournement de fond
l'indépendance de la justice est-ce que
vous avez une notion de ça ou est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus c'est un
petit peu surprenant que on soit enfin
silencieux sur le sujet voilà en ce qui
me concerne et je vais passer vraiment
que vous vouliez me répondre peut-être
directement et puis on passe la parole
au collègues
oui bien sûr je peux vous répondre sur
sur ces questions sur la proposition sur
le marché de l'électricité la Commission
a fait une proposition qui a été rendue
publique à la fin de l'année ou qui est
pour consultation publique depuis
mi-janvier donc à peu près maintenant en
fait ça va commencer le prochain conseil
énergie étant en mars et plutôt fin mars
si mon souvenir est bon
il y a
deux objectifs dans cette réforme le
premier est évidemment de faire baisser
les prix et la pression sur les
entreprises et les consommateurs le
deuxième est de faire cela en ne
sacrifiant pas à nos objectifs de
transition énergétique donc à ce stade
dans la proposition on garderait
effectivement une forme de mériteur qui
permettrait de de s'assurer que nous
incitons toujours à la transition
énergétique et en même temps
effectivement on privilégierait on
donner plus de poids au prix de
production en quelque sorte de façon
intégrer le fait que certaines
productions énergétiques coûtent moins
cher que le gaz surtout en cette en
cette période c'est le début d'une
période de consultation donc bien sûr ça
peut ça peut parfaitement évoluer
[Musique]
oui le public je crois que tout le monde
peut y répondre absolument
oui il faut pouvait vous pouvez
parfaitement la regarder le calendrier
et pour respecter la démocratie
parlementaire aussi mais sa pensée que
si ces discussions donc c'est l'énergie
de mars est difficile d'avoir un texte
officiel avant avril ensuite iris
d'avoir des très longues donc le la
capacité à
endosser dans le cadre des trilogues
parlementaires habituel cette réforme du
marché d'électricité
notamment avec l'arrêt des travaux que
vous mentionnez va être tendu donc nous
allons regarder s'il y a d'autres
procédures qui permettent d'accélérer
tout en respectant la procédure
démocratique et nous pour en parler la
prochaine fois qu'on se voit je crois
que ce sera important sinon il faudra
préserver des mesures d'urgence qui ont
été mis en place cette année de façon à
préserver les mesures de soutien aux
entreprises et au ménages qui avaient
été mises en œuvre
sur
une flèche de réduction Act et la
faiblesse de l'omsi comme vous savez les
Américains ne sont pas présents
n'ont pas rempli de postes qui étaient
disponibles et c'est sûr alors je
voudrais dire deux choses ici quelle que
soit quel que soit la force ou la
faiblesse de l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce il est extrêmement important je
crois que l'Europe préserve ses valeurs
ne soient pas et ne soit pas naïve donc
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on a
des outils en fait pour faire face aux
subventions induites d'autres pays que
nous n'avons pas encore utilisé puisque
ils ont été créés pendant la présidente
française de l'Union européenne c'est
par exemple l'anti l'outil anti
subventions qui a été publiée au Journal
officiel avant la fin de l'année et qui
va être effectif dans le courant de
cette année et en clair cet outil anti
subventions il permet d'analyser ici sur
un marché par exemple l'automobile au
hasard un état qui vendrait des autos en
France et trop largement subventionné
par une entreprise qui vendrait des
automobiles en France et largement
subventionnés par un état on le
documente et dans ce cas-là on remet des
tarifs sur ces voitures et donc pas de
naïveté et respect du droit je crois que
c'est absolument ce que nous devons
faire en européen vous m'avez parlé du
traité franco-espagnol qui effectivement
il y a le sommet jeudi prochain le 19
janvier
date chargée donc
c'est un traité d'amitié un peu comme ce
qui avec les mêmes esprits que pour
l'Italie il va nous permettre de
réaffirmer ces valeurs communes que sont
l'état de droit il va y avoir des
coopérations concrètes comme les
interconnexions électriques et on essaye
de lancer aussi une dynamique pour la
coopération policière et judiciaire
voilà il faut absolument que ce soit
dans le respect des principes que vous
rappeliez et on pourra revenir en parler
si vous voulez lors d'une prochaine
audition j'essaye en fait juste de faire
que nous ayons beaucoup plus de décision
pour que nous puissions nous parler plus
souvent
on va prendre des questions par trois
parce que la liste s'est allongée donc
je vais demander à Pascal Alizard Claude
Kern et Alain Cadec de lancer le
merci monsieur le Président ministre
merci pour toutes les précisions que
vous venez de nous donner j'aurai en
fait une réflexion préliminaire et une
question si vous le voulez bien la
réflexion c'est pour aller dans le sens
des propos de Jean-François Rapin
concernant effectivement les rapports
entre le Parlement européen et les
parlements nationaux on est un certain
nombre autour de cette table
effectivement pratiqué la diplomatie
parlementaire et avoir une expérience
une petite expérience sur le sujet et je
crois qu'effectivement trop souvent les
parlements nationaux sont peu considérés
ça peut même aller jusqu'à ce qu'on nous
demande d'écouter ce qu'on avait à nous
dire et d'être les relais sur nos
territoires de ce qui était décidé à
Bruxelles ça m'est arrivé
personnellement et je crois je suis un
Européen convaincu et je crois que
l'Europe ne progressera pas je crains
même qu'elle régresse si on devait
encourager ou persévérer dans ce type de
comportement donc je crois qu'on a
vraiment à inverser la chose là-dessus
il faut que les parlements nationaux et
leur place dans le dispositif
je crains que si on se rate là-dessus on
va renforcer les extrêmes et des
extrêmes qui n'ont pas du tout la même
vision que nous de l'Europe et des
avantages qu'elle peut procurer ça
c'était la remarque ma question en fait
porte sur les relations avec la Turquie
il se trouve qu'hier matin l'ambassadeur
turc à Paris était assis à votre place
devant la commission des affaires
étrangères et et on a passé trois heures
alors c'est c'est un homme brillant un
grand diplomate et Narc de la même
promotion que le Président de la
République ça a été trois heures de
langue de bois fantastique bon je pars
détailler ça on n'a pas
dit ça j'ai pas dit ça mais tu as le
droit de faire le remarque mais c'est
pas la mienne
ma question est en fait la suivante
c'est vous en tant que ministre aux
Affaires européennes avec vos collègues
des autres pays comment vivez-vous la
relation avec la Turquie quand on voit
la Turquie qui qui finalement
à une position mouvante en permanence et
qui veut s'imposer notamment dans le
conflit ukrainien comme l'interlocuteur
privilégié vis-à-vis de la Russie ce qui
est quand même pas si évident que ça
enfin voilà il y a tout un tas de
comportements actuels du président
Erdogan qui qui pose question et qui
inquiète les rapports avec la Grèce les
rapports avec Chypre les problématiques
de de de
d'énergie de gaz etc donc ma question
porte pas sur ces sujets là mais ma
question porte sur comment avec vos
collègues de l'Union vous vous envisagez
la relation avec avec la et comment vous
essayez de prévenir à ces assez
comportement s'il vous plaît
plaît merci président madame la ministre
la Suède a précisé il y a quelques jours
ces ambitions pour sa présidence de
l'Union européenne
savoir la sécurité l'unité de la
compétitivité la transition verte l'État
de droit naturellement nous adhérons à
ces objectifs
cependant nous nous interrogeons
interrogeons sur les suites des
conclusions de la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'Europe vivement c'est
conclusions avaient été adoptées en
avril dernier et depuis pratiquement
rien pour faire vivre ses conclusions et
surtout leur traduction par des actes
semble au point mort
alors
ma question est la suivante la France
continuera-t-elle à œuvrer pour faire
émerger un consensus autour de ses
propositions et ainsi permettre une
action européenne plus efficace
oui madame la ministre
moi je voudrais vous vous
rappeler les propos que j'avais tenu
lors de l'échange que nous avions eu
avant le avant le dernier Conseil
européen et notamment
je vous avais interrogé sur le fait que
il sera nécessaire à mes yeux d'évaluer
le résultat des sanctions qui ont été
prises contre la Russie et de savoir si
vraiment ça avait porté ses fruits comme
on nous le dit
et que une un état des lieux était était
nécessaire mais c'est également vrai
pour les pays contributeurs
parce que c'est par le tout prendre des
sanctions mais les sanctions impliquent
des des
retours de bâtons économiques et on les
connaît déjà en termes d'énergie mais
bien dans d'autres domaines qui
impactent les pays
qui appliquent ces sanctions c'est vrai
d'ailleurs depuis 2014 depuis l'invasion
de la Crimée et les sanctions étaient
mises en place au niveau européen donc
est-ce que vous avez fait cette
évaluation est-ce que vous l'avez
proposé est-ce que la France est prête à
mettre sur la table ce qu'il en est
précisément ça c'est la première
question la deuxième question elle
reprend un peu ce que disais le
président rappin tout à l'heure
par rapport à ce que à la décision qui a
été prise au conseil donc du du soutien
et notamment à l'Ukraine que qu'on
partage tous ici et notamment sur ces 18
milliards
c'est 18 milliards pour 2023 qui sont
dessinés à financer des services publics
essentiels les hôpitaux enfin bon un
certain nombre de choses comme ça et à
remettre en état les infrastructures
les garanties pour ce prêt donc sont
fournis par le budget de l'Union
européenne
ou par les États membres je voudrais
savoir un petit peu et puis quelle est
la participation de la France sur ces 18
milliards
alors est-ce que c'est au prorata ta
participation au budget de l'Union
européenne est-ce que c'est un chiffre
qui a été décidé au sein du Conseil
voilà c'est les deux questions que je
voulais vous je voulais vous poser ce
matin le ministre
merci beaucoup
ce que vous dites sur les parlements
nationaux et
ce que je comprends comme la volonté
d'un meilleur dialogue et plus
approfondie entre
entre le Parlement européen et les
parlements nationaux
d'une certaine façon alors je me
garderai bien de commenter et de mettre
le doigt dans la porte de l'ingérence
dans le Parlement mais il y a
je crois qu'il y a deux choses il y a la
première c'est je pense que le dialogue
constant est utile à tous les niveaux et
que ce dialogue entre Parlement
nationaux et Parlement européen est
important
vous avez beaucoup de procédures qui
permettent aussi je crois de dialoguer
et de mettre votre pâte sur la
la réglementation européenne notamment à
travers la commission des affaires
européennes à la fois par le contrôle de
subsidiarité par le dialogue politique
aux institutions et puis les résolutions
européennes pour pour et ce sont des
moyens de bien exprimer la position des
parlements après on peut on peut
réfléchir
nous à comment comment on fait parler
aussi de façon équilibrée avec les deux
par exemple c'est quelque chose croit
dont nous avions discuté avec le
président de cette commission lorsque je
me déplace et je sollicite généralement
des parlementaires nationaux et
européens de façon à avoir les deux à la
fois et si ce type d'action vous semble
intéressant je serai ravi de le
renouveler l'étendre et le faire plus
fréquemment
voilà et puis je vais aussi transmettre
vos inquiétudes à nos amis européens
je l'entends oui absolument
sur vous m'avez également parlé des
relations avec la Turquie ce qui est je
crois
point intéressant puisque comme vous le
savez le procédure la Turquie avait
déposé sa demande d'adhésion 87 obtenu
le statut de candidat en 99 et voilà ça
paraît tellement loin que je pense que
c'est utile ce qui me semble et c'est
aussi pour cela que la communauté
politique européenne est importante
parce qu'elle permet d'avoir un dialogue
politique avec des pays qui ne sont pas
candidats
je crois qu'il faut qu'on reconnaisse
que la Turquie a été éloigne des valeurs
et de l'acquis de l'Union européenne et
le dernier rapport de la Commission sur
la Turquie qui a été publiée le 12
octobre 2022 fait était en particulier
de recul en matière de droit
fondamentaux d'indépendance de la
justice et de fonctionnement des
institutions démocratiques
et notamment il y a eu l'adoption comme
vous savez l'année dernière d'une loi
sur la désinformation
qui évidemment soulève bien des
interrogations sur la liberté
d'expression en Turquie
il y a aussi et c'est dans le rapport de
la commission est la perception que la
politique étrangère d'Ankara et en
porte-à-faux par rapport à la politique
étrangère et de sécurité de l'Union
européenne et c'est aussi un constat que
nous partageons
voilà donc en bref j'ai envie de dire
que nous sommes il y a effectivement un
sentiment d'inquiétude entre les États
membres et notamment et vous évoquiez
sur la Grèce ici prévient une répétition
de déclaration assez menaçante et la
position d'un carat sur la question
chypriote évidemment pas très très
évidente dans ce contexte voilà après
étant donné la situation géopolitique au
niveau bilatéral il faut que nous
continuions de leur parler il faut
également travailler avec la Turquie
parce que il y a les procédures
d'adhésion de la Finlande et de la Suède
à l'OTAN et j'ai pas facile comme vous
avez pu le voir là aussi il y a des il y
a des tensions
l'approche de l'Union européenne c'est
un peu
elle essaie de jouer avec tout ça
notamment en plus avec le rôle d'Ankara
dans la médiation et sur sur la guerre
avec la Russie sur le fait de pouvoir
passer comme vous savez des bateaux avec
des produits alimentaires vers l'Afrique
donc
progressif proportionné et réversible
c'est la position d'Union Européenne
mais c'est vrai que c'est une position
délicate
et comme vous voyez il y a assez peu de
dialogues à l'heure actuelle
il y a des dialogues institutionnels et
au niveau mais finalement ça diffuse
assez peu ce qui est un symptôme de
d'en parler avec vous un peu plus
ambilatérale aussi
sur les suites de la coiffeuse
je crois que c'est vrai on a été un peu
déçu par les difficultés à obtenir
à la fois de la présidence du Conseil
l'année dernière dans la deuxième partie
de l'année et la Commission du Parlement
un peu plus enthousiasme sur un rendu
qui soit plus important avec les
citoyens voilà c'est le dialogue aux
citoyen est un petit peu décemment après
la Commission a bien pris un acte de ce
qui de tout ce qui est remonté de la
cofeu et je crois que nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en discuter des mesures qui
étaient déjà prises l'intérêt pour une
Europe de la santé sur lequel la
Commission va européenne va travailler
puisque je crois que ce qui restera
lorsqu'on va s'approcher des élections
européennes c'est vraiment le succès du
vaccin de l'opération vaccin qui a
permis de vacciner tout le monde et sans
lutte fratricide entre les pays de
l'Union européenne pour obtenir des
vaccins ça je crois que c'est essentiel
maintenant il reste à approfondir et
réapproprier le dialogue avec les
citoyens et ça en fait c'est ça a trait
à la façon dont nos institutions
fonctionnent
et à l'occasion du Conseil des ministres
franco-al nous reviendrons sur ce sujet
et je serais ravi d'en parler avec vous
également après
monsieur
le sénateur Cadec
oui nous travaillons beaucoup à la fois
sur l'impact des sanctions mais je crois
la première chose remarque que je
voudrais faire
ce n'est pas que les sanctions qui vont
nous aider à faire que l'Ukraine gagne
cette guerre et que s'impose de craindre
la démocratie sur le continent européen
c'est le paquet de sanctions de soutien
humanitaires d'abord à l'Ukraine de
soutien financier et de soutien
militaire donc je crois qu'il faut
toujours garder ça
en tête ensuite comment est-ce que nous
évènements l'impact de substinction donc
comme vous savez il y a eu plus de 9
trains de sanction qui ne sont pas non
qui ne sont pas seulement européennes
mais qui passent par le G7 et par plus
de 40 pays un non européen et qui sont
notamment traditionnellement neutre
il y a des sanctions sur le pétrole
russe
et le pétrole russe comme vous savez ça
représentait 90% de l'approvisionnement
en pétrole de l'Union européenne donc
c'est la privilégie d'énormément de
revenus quand à nous pour l'instant les
prix se comportent bien et le marché du
pétrole à la fois sur l'offre et le de
la demande et à peu près stable nous
suivons cela comme le nez sur le feu
notamment avec nos amis américains que
qui était à Paris par exemple cette
semaine donc ça c'est important et on va
suivre il va y avoir une nouvelle étape
d'évaluation en février ces revues de
façon régulière de façon à s'assurer que
ça ne nous pénalise pas nous mais que sa
pénalise bien
la Russie
en matière de produits technologies
avancés qui croient une des plus belles
sanctions la Russie dépend à 45% l'Union
européenne donc c'est près de la moitié
de son approvisionnement 21% des
États-Unis et 11% seulement de la Chine
donc lorsqu'on met des tensions sur les
produits de technologie avancés on l'a
pris d'à peu près 2/3 de son
approvisionnement et comme vous savez la
Chine n'a pas atteint le niveau de
développement technologique des
États-Unis et de l'Europe c'est
d'ailleurs bien
une des affaires sur lesquelles les
États-Unis sont très forts donc et avec
ça les sanctions affaiblissent la Russie
dans tous les secteurs soyez semis
conducteurs sur l'aéronautique sur
l'automobile je crois qu'il faut voir en
images comment en Russie on essaye de
réparer des voitures c'est en désossant
de vieilles voitures parce que c'est
impossible d'importer des pièces de
rechange les avions sont cloués au sol
donc ça c'est absolument important
d'ailleurs la production automobile en
Russie a chuté de 97% en 2022 par
rapport à 2021 il y a plus d'airbags
dans les voitures c'est très concret il
y a plus de boîte automatique dans la
voiture c'est également très concret et
à nouveau sur l'aviation je pense que
c'est encore plus important parce que
comme vous savez les
technologies sont généralement dual donc
en pénalisant l'aviation civile c'est
bien sûr l'aviation de défense que nous
finalisions aussi et puis il y a une
chose qui est très importante depuis le
début de la guerre il y a une fuite des
cerveaux massive de la Russie et donc on
a prive de ses élites et de personnels
qualifiés notamment scientifiques qui
est de beaucoup de personnes qui
cherchent à partir et qui partent à la
fois en France aux États-Unis ou
ailleurs une chose sera d'être sûre que
nous sommes suffisamment attractifs pour
que ces cerveaux aient envie de venir
chez nous plutôt que chez nos voisins
occidentaux
sur
oui absolument alors l'assistance
macro-financière donc effectivement la
commission empreinte des fonds sur les
marchés et elle les transfère avec
l'Ukraine et pour emprunter ses fonds le
prêt est garanti à hauteur de 70% par
l'Union par le budget de l'Union
européenne
et le budget de l'Union européenne
lui-même couvre les frais d'intérêt donc
l'impact sur le cadre financier pluriel
c'est ce que vous avez en tête et assez
limité et ensuite la participation elle
se fait de mémoire à peu près à
proportion du PIB de chaque pays dans
l'Union européenne donc elle est
parfaitement juste
vous savez ce qu'on nous reproche et ce
n'est pas de faire ça c'est de ne pas
être assez rapide et de ne pas faire
suffisamment sous forme de don
voilà
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre je voudrais ajouter ma pierre
au débat qui a été lancé par mon
collègue Alizard j'ai participé à la
demande du président de la commission le
1er décembre dernier à une réunion au
Parlement européen qui avait invité
d'ailleurs des parlementaires nationaux
pour parler des questions d'État de
droit de liberté des médias d'agérence
dans le système
dans le système électoral européen et
c'est vrai qu'en échangeant avec mes
collègues euros parlementaires j'ai été
étonné un de la méconnaissance qu'ils
avaient du travail que nous réalisions
au niveau des parlements nationaux mais
plus encore de ce que nous faisons à
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
la commission mais aussi le Parlement
européen surtout le
sous la pression du Parlement bien la
Commission veut de plus en plus prendre
sa part dans on va dire la protection le
contrôle la définition de l'État de
droit mais sans tenir compte de
l'existence enfin on y reviendra mais
nous avons fait un avis motivé en
décembre sur le projet de règlement sur
la liberté des médias ce projet est très
mal fichu la proposition de règlement
proposé par la Commission ne résoudra
pas pour avoir fait un rapport avec jean
Bizet et mon ami Jean-Yves Lemoine sur
l'état de droit en Hongrie il y a quoi
deux ans maintenant un an et demi un an
et un an et demi et nous sommes allés
sur place
les instruments de régulation qui sont
proposés ne résolvent en rien le
problème de la liberté des médias
Hongrie donc je pense que là on a un
vrai souci dans l'échange la percolation
entre les parlements nationaux
autres organisations qui sont composées
de parlementaires européens le Parlement
européen et la Commission voilà c'est un
bref aparté moi la question je voulais
poser ça se crée un petit peu en marge
du Conseil européen des 15 et 16
décembre dernier mais hier
directement il y avait le 14 décembre
dernier en amont dont du conseiller
européen
un sommet Union européenne azéane qui
regroupe 10 pays du Sud-Est asiatique
organisé entre eux économiquement un
certain nombre de questions se posent
parce que le laséal fait l'objet d'un
regard très attentif naturellement de la
Chine mais aussi des États-Unis puisque
Joe Biden c'est rendu le 12 novembre
dernier au sommet de l'azéanne avec un
discours politique d'ailleurs de
coopération assez proche celui de
l'Union européenne rajoutant quand même
une dimension de alors et des tas de
droit qu'on n'a pas dans le discours de
la Commission on nous parle un petit peu
de sécurité on est très prudent tout le
monde inscrit cela dans un
ado Pacifique libre et ouvert à tous que
ce soit les États-Unis et et la
commission enfin tous les cas l'Union
européenne moi ce qui me préoccupe
aujourd'hui c'est que quelle politique
cohérente j'ai eu la chance à travers la
commission des affaires étrangères et
quelques collègues nous allons sortir
très prochainement un rapport sur la
place de la France d'un ado pacifique de
nous être rendu donc en adopacifique on
a de Daisy à Jakarta nous avons nous
sommes allés au siège de l'azéanne nous
avons eu les représentants de l'Union
européenne auprès de la zéane nous
n'avons pas été fascinés par le niveau
je dirais de technicité en tous les cas
des réponses qu'on nous a données on a
un ensemble qui apparaît effectivement
cohérent au regard de l'Union européenne
mais qui est extrêmement hétérogène qui
subit parfois des dépendances ou des
influences
à l'égard de la Chine ou d'autres par
rapport aux États-Unis qui fait que
quand je lis dans dans le compte-rendu
qu'on envisage alors certes on définit
pas le terme l'élaboration d'un traité
de libre-échange entre l'Union
européenne et l'azéanne je me pose la
question de comment on fait avec tout
les systèmes d'accord que nous avons
entre les pays avec qui on a déjà un
système de libre-échange le Vietnam
Singapour d'autres avec qui on a des
accords partenariats d'autres qui
bénéficient des systèmes préférentiels
tout sauf les armes extrêmement
avantageux Birmanie la hausse Cambodge
etc et les pays avec qu'on n'a pas
d'accord donc moi j'ai vraiment du mal à
comprendre au-delà du discours de
l'importance d'avoir un dialogue avec
lazean surtout avec son sa principale
composante qui aujourd'hui l'Indonésie
je vois pas comment on va avancer alors
quelques projets global get way sur
l'interconnectivité ou autre ou de
développement durable comment on pourra
un partenaire comme il est envisagé
parce que derrière tout ça se cache
l'idée que la Chine va de moins en moins
être un partenaire y compris économique
dans la chaîne de production et que un
espace de 620 millions d'habitants celui
de l'azéade pour être une sorte de
substitution dans la chaîne de valeur
notamment européenne
à une éventuelle défaillance ou
complexité avec la Chine en tous les cas
on aurait besoin parce que c'est un
enjeu et qui est géré par l'Union
européenne d'avoir un peu plus
d'informants d'informations à ce sujet
au niveau du Parlement nationaux je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre 4 questions d'abord sur l'état
de droit mais d'une autre d'un autre
point de vue vous savez combien la Cour
de justice l'Union européenne est
sensible sur la question des données de
connexion pourtant depuis un peu plus
d'une année nous voyons qu'il y a au
moins deux pays la Grèce et la Pologne
qui ont utilisé le logiciel Pegasus pour
surveiller leurs oppositions
or on s'aperçoit aussi que les
institutions en interne sont pas
capables d'investiguer correctement sur
la manière dont les choses se sont
passées c'est un sujet majeur en termes
d'État de droit
est-ce que puisque finalement en fait
les réunions des conseils entre chef
d'État et de gouvernement sont des
réunions on essaie de faire avancer les
dossiers quand les dossiers posent
problème on les évoque pas est-ce que
ces sujets sont évoqués et comment
est-ce qu'on peut
faire avancer ce qui est un sujet majeur
en matière d'état de droit dans dans ces
deux pays en particulier en Grèce compte
tenu de la manière dont les choses se
sont passées cette semaine deuxième
question sur les questions de
concurrence
nous avons vu la mise en oeuvre la corde
sur le mécanisme carbone aux frontières
qui finalement en fait un outil pour
éviter les distorsions de concurrence
dès lors que le prix du carbone est
différent entre les différents zones de
production est-ce que ce type de
mécanisme pourrait aussi être mise en
œuvre lorsqu'on constate des différences
de coût sur des questions d'énergie ou
sur d'autres choses enfin j'entends par
là que à partir du moment où on observe
qu'il y a des distorsions de concurrence
comme avec ce qui est en train de se
passer aux États-Unis compte tenu d'un
certain nombre de subventions ou de
coûts d'énergie qui sont différents
est-ce que ce qu'on a mis en place qu'on
est en train de mettre en place en
matière de coût du carbone on pourrait
aussi le mettre en place dans le cadre
de l'on parce que ça marche avec l'ONE
c'est compatible avec le MC à partir du
moment on constate que d'autres coûts
d'autres paramètres des coûts des
entreprises sont différents et pose un
problème de concurrence aux entreprises
européennes troisième sujet est-ce que
vous pouvez nous faire un point sur la
mise en oeuvre du contrôle entrée sortie
Schengen et Ethias et ce qui bloque
parce que il semble ce sera pas mis en
oeuvre en 2023 donc ce nous nous donner
des informations là dessus enfin dernier
point vous avez évoqué les 18 milliards
d'euros pour l'Ukraine ça correspond à
peu près à deux mois et demi de besoin
budgétaires de de ce pays on constate
aussi que nous avons besoin de nouvelles
recettes en matière de défense en
matière de transition
énergétique
est-ce que parmi les
objectifs de de la prochaine rencontre
franco-allemande vous mettez
l'idée de réfléchir à de nouvelles
recettes réelles et propres pour l'Union
européenne des recettes durables
c'est-à-dire pas de recette qui s'appuie
sur des choses qui doivent disparaître
comme l'usage des plastiques ou le
carbone est-ce que ça fait partie de
votre agenda pour relancer la relation
franco-allemande de trouver des
nouvelles recettes à l'Union européenne
pour tous ces ambitions qui sont pas
financées pour l'instant
oui madame la ministre brièvement le
dernier Conseil européen a dû répondre à
l'actualité comment soutenait l'Ukraine
militairement comment renouveler les
capacités de matériel de défense de pays
européens qui contribuent à la défense
de l'Ukraine
qu'en est-il d'une Europe militaire dont
on avait parlé au début du conflit dont
on ne parle plus beaucoup aujourd'hui
d'autant plus que le principal allié
français sur le plan militaire était la
Grande-Bretagne jusque ces dernières
années et qu'aujourd'hui la
Grande-Bretagne heureusement est encore
coopérante avec la France mais
la Grande-Bretagne n'est plus dans
l'Europe qu'en est-il d'une Europe
militaire sachant que c'est un
engagement long terme il va falloir une
dizaine d'années pour habitué
véritablement une Europe de la défense
s'il y avait une volonté aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a encore un peu de
volonté dans ce sens
merci merci beaucoup pour vos questions
alors dans l'ordre
monsieur le sénateur
gâteau
il fallait reprendre sur
sur la liberté des
sur la liberté des médias comme vous
savez c'est c'est un texte qui est en
cours et nous sommes particulièrement
l'idée c'est quand même de protéger la
liberté d'expression et la justesse des
informations
à la fois dans les médias traditionnels
et dans les médias numériques comme ce
texte est en cours notre analyse est
aussi en cours nous serons
particulièrement vigilants et sur le
fait de préserver c'est de piliers c'est
de principes et que ce soit compatible
bien évidemment avec ce qui avec les
acquis que nous avons
sur
le sommet eu Asian
il y a plusieurs choses je suis en train
de je voulais vous faire part mais
il y a énormément d'accord concrets et
l'idée c'est effectivement arrêter je ne
peux plus
j'en ai beaucoup trop et donc voilà
merci
je crois que vous avez raison de dire
que ça ne peut pas être que un espace de
discussion c'est essentiel les espaces
de discussion quand même ça permet de se
comprendre de s'écouter de s'entendre
quand j'écoute ce que vous dites sur la
cosaque je me dis qu'effectivement avoir
un espace de réflexion c'est déjà énorme
maintenant qu'est-ce qui s'est passé de
façon plus concrète sur ce sommet
d'abord il y a un plan d'action
easyan sur la période 2023 à 2027
ensuite il y a l'investissement alors
j'ai entendu votre scepticisme sur le
Global getaway qui est quand même 10
milliards et c'est quelque chose qui est
partagé j'allais dire puisque nous
sommes en train d'accélérer sur le fait
de mettre en place des projets concrets
dans ce qui est concret il y a eu un
accord de transport aérien et ça je
crois que ça c'est très important
notamment pour garder les liens on le
sait tous et puis
sur il y a aussi eu des discussions sur
la Russie et l'Ukraine parce
qu'évidemment nous nous souhaitons pas
de contournement des sanctions mais que
le plus de pays possible puissent
s'aligner sur ce qui a été décidé et
enfin il y en a eu sur le défi
climatique qui est environnemental
où là il y a deux sujets quand même
d'une part il y a des sujets de
financement comme vous savez et il faut
absolument qu'on progresse là dessus et
des sujets de transfert technologiques
sur lesquels nous espérons progresser
aussi et puis je le disais c'est un
espace de réunion politique qui est en
marche du sommeil il y a eu deux accords
de partenariats de coopération à la fois
entre l'Union européenne et la Thaïlande
et puis aussi entre l'Union européenne
et la Malaisie
et à nouveau dans le cadre géopolitique
qui est une autre je crois que si
vraiment important de continuer d'être
là et d'avancer sur des projets concrets
ça sera plus simple
vous m'avez interrogé sur les données de
mes interrogés sur beaucoup de choses
les données de connexion l'État de droit
la question de Pégase les questions de
concurrence Schengen et les relations
franco allemande alors si vous voulez
bien je vais commencer par
par Pegasus et État de droit je crois
je vais compter sur vous pour en parler
aussi mais l'état de droit c'est le
sujet qui nous occupe le plus et pour de
bonnes raisons parce que je crois qu'il
conditionne tout ce qui reste sur la
démocratie que ce soit la corruption que
ce soit indépendance de la justice que
ce soit la pluralité des médias et leur
liberté que ce soit les processus
démocratiques c'est vraiment les piliers
sur lesquels on agit et ceux qui
distinguent l'Europe de ses voisins et
notamment de celui qui est agressif en
ce moment donc c'est extrêmement
important pour nous ça fait deux ans je
crois au 3 que la Commission fait un
point annuel sur l'état de droit dans
tous les pays y compris le nôtre
d'ailleurs et éventuellement déclenche
des procédures
la question de Pegasus va être examinée
dans cette
dans ce rapport annuel que fait la
commission bien évidemment et puis comme
vous le savez le Parlement européen
c'est aussi saisi de cette affaire et
nous nous allons poser oui des pareilles
de cette affaire et il y a aussi des
affaires au Parlement européen sur un
petit nombre de personnes sur lesquelles
évidemment je ne peux pas commenter la
justice et en cours mais que je ne peux
que déplorer
parce que vous parliez de démocratie
évidemment une affaire de corruption
c'est un coût pour nous et c'est un
énorme coup de tonnerre mais orage dans
une période pré électorale voilà mais
nous allons continuer au sein du conseil
à faire générale de suivre ces sujets à
l'État de droit et notamment le rapport
qui aura lieu sur sur la Grèce
et en général il y a une assez grande
unité aussi sur ces sujets notamment en
franco-allemand sur le sujet de
concurrence et comme ce que vous avez
noté sur sur une flèche réduction Act
le
alors le mécanisme
du mécanisme de taxation frontières du
carbone enfin des produits qui ne sont
pas aussi des carbonés que les nôtres
c'est quelque chose que nous allons
tester et piloter pendant trois ans
comme vous le savez et la taxe a eu des
produits carbonés c'est nous qui la
mettons il y a dans d'autres anciens
internationales
une évaluation de toutes les politiques
de bicarbonation pour voir si par
exemple des subventions telles que le
pratiquent les États-Unis permettent de
décarboner autant que ce que l'Europe
fait avec la taxe carbone et dans si
c'était le cas comment est-ce qu'on peut
faire des accords entre les deux régions
pour s'assurer que nous atteignons tous
le même objectif moi je crois que là on
parle de choses un peu différentes parce
que ce n'est pas une subvention
seulement pour des carboner on peut s'en
réjouir ça c'est sûr mais c'est une
subvention pour faciliter la production
sur le sol américain qui quand on leur
ajoute effectivement au prix d'énergie
et un vrai coup pour la compétitive
compétitivité de nos entreprises et deux
offres et de nos emplois
le prix d'énergie c'est pas une volonté
délibérée des américains avec des
subventions ou des taxes de le faire
monter le prix d'énergie que